>> WELCOME BACK VERY ON MONDAY
THE NATION WILL OBSERVE MEMORIA
DAY, A SACRED DAY TO HONOR THOS
WHO HAVE MADE THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE IN HONOR OF THIS
COUNTRY GREAT AHEAD OF THIS
IMPORTANT DAY, FOX NEWS DIGITAL
SPOKE TO AN ARMY VETERAN WHO
SERVED DURING THE BATTLE OF
MOGADISHU WHICH WAS PORTRAYED I
THE FILM BLACK HAWK DOWN
WORMLIKE 18 AMERICAN SOLDIERS
LOST THEIR LIVES GREAT HERE IS
TOM REFLECTING ON THAT FATEFUL
DAY.
>> WE WERE TRYING TO STOP OR
LOAD FROM STARVING MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE TO DEATH.
>> IT STARTED TO HEAT UP AND
THEN ONE HELICOPTER GOT SHOT
DOWN.
I COULD HEAR IT CRASH OFF IN TH
DISTANCE.
EVERYTHING CHANGED.
EVERYTHING CHANGED GREAT IT WAS
NOW A RESCUE MISSION.
WE WENT ON FOOT, THE SECONDARY
WENT ON FOOT TO THE CRASH SITE
TO TRY TO SAVE LIVES AND RECOVE
THE BODIES THEY DIDN'T MAKE IT.
THAT'S WHEN THEY PINNED US DOWN.
THAT FEELING OF BEING TRAPPED
AND YOU JUST WANT TO GO HOME, H
JUST WANTED TO BE OVER.
THAT'S WHEN YOU REALIZE IT'S
REAL COMBAT AND YOU CAN'T JUST
GO HOME.
AND THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO GO
HOME.
THEY WANT YOU DEAD RIGHT THERE.
IF YOU COULD IMAGINE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE THAT WANT YOU DEAD,
IT'S THE MOST HORRIFYING THING
YOU'VE EVER BEEN THROUGH.
>> NOW, AFTER A CAREER IN THE
SPECIAL FORCES, TOM EXPERIENCED
SEVERE PTSD THAT EVEN LEAD TO
THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE, HIS LIFE
WAS SAVED BY THE LOVE OF HIS
WIFE JANET, AND TOGETHER THEY
CREATED THE ALL SECURE
FOUNDATION TO HELP HIS FELLOW
VETERANS FEEL HEALED FROM THE
TRAUMA OF WAR, AND I'M HONORED
TO HAVE TOM AND JAN JOIN ME
RIGHT NOW, AND GREAT TO MEET
BOTH OF YOU.
I HAVE TO SAY ESPECIALLY, WE
KNOW MEMORIAL DAY IS THOSE FOR
THOSE WHO DID NOT MAKE IT HOME,
BUT TOM, WE LIVE IN A WORLD NOW
WITH WAR AND WITH MEDICAL HELP
AND WITH FIGHT WHERE WE ARE
SURVIVING, OUR TROOPS YOU CAN G
THERE, GET SEVERELY INJURED AND
SURVIVE, AND WE'RE ABLE TO BRIN
YOU HOME OR EVEN WITH THE IED'S
AND EVERYTHING, SO WE HAVE MORE
OF OUR TROOPS COMING HOME WHO I
WORLD WAR II WOULD HAVE DIED ON
THE SCENE LEAVING US WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE HAD
INEXPRESSIBLE AND USUALLY
UNKNOWABLE EXECUTE EXPERIENCES
WE NEVER WOULD'VE HAD BEFORE.
THIS IS I THINK WHAT REALLY WE
ARE NOW DEALING WITH HERE IN TH
COUNTRY AND WHAT YOUR FOUNDATIO
ADDRESSES.
>> ABSOLUTELY, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US ON.
WE USED TO CALL IT THE INVISIBL
WOUNDS OF WAR, BUT NOW WE KNOW
YOU CAN CONDUCT BRAIN SCANS AND
IT'S ACTUALLY AN INJURY THAT CA
BE TREATED.
THERE IS HOPE FOR MANY PEOPLE
OUT THERE THAT WOULD TYPICALLY
THINK THIS IS A LIFE SENTENCE
FOR IT.
>> JAN, WE ARE SEEING A LOT,
IT'S BEEN A DIFFICULT WEEK FOR
THE COUNTRY BUT EVERYTHING WERE
DEALING WITH, BUT ONE THING WE
HAVE SEEN WELL FOR YEARS NOW IS
THAT IT IS WOMEN WHO BEGIN TO
MAKE THE DIFFERENCE, WHO ARE
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THEIR HUSBANDS, WITH THEIR LOVE
ONES, WITH THEIR FAMILIES
DEFENDING THEIR CHILDREN AND
LOOK INTO THE FUTURE.
WHEN YOU SAVED YOUR HUSBAND'S
LIFE AND YOU STARTED UP THIS
BUSINESS TO SAVE MORE PEOPLE,
WAS THIS SOMETHING YOU IMAGINE
DOING.
WAS THIS SOMETHING THAT CAME
NATURAL FOR YOU OR WAS IT KIND
OF DIFFICULT AND A SURPRISE?
>> AT THINK IT'S BOTH.
I STARTED SERVING ALONGSIDE TOM
IN SPECIAL OPERATIONS IS A
CAMERA AND FILM PERSON AND GOT
REALLY INSIDE LOOK VERY ONE SID
STARTED LEARNING ABOUT THE
EPIDEMIC OF THE SUICIDES THAT
WERE PLAGUING THIS COMMUNITY, I
COULDN'T TURN THE OTHER WAY.
I DON'T THINK THIS WAS SOMETHIN
I GREW UP DREAMING ABOUT, BUT
I'M CERTAINLY GLAD I'M HERE AND
HONORED TO BE HERE.
>> GOD HAS A FUNNY WAY OF HAVIN
A PLAN FOR US, BUT THE LITTLE
ADAGE OF WE MAKE PLANS AND GOD
LAUGHS.
RIGHT?
AND THIS IS, IT'S ABOUT
FOLLOWING YOU KNOW OUR PATH,
EVEN THOUGH IT'S WHEN WE COULD
NOT HAVE IMAGINED.
WHAT DOES YOUR FOUNDATION DO?
WE KNOW WE ARE BEGINNING TO
UNDERSTAND PTSD JUST THAT IT
EXISTS, AND NOW WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW DO WE HELP.
WHAT DOES YOUR FOUNDATION DO
EXACTLY AND WHAT DO YOU SEE IS
REALLY THE GREAT APPROACH, THE
BEST APPROACH TO HELP OUR
WOUNDED WARRIORS?
>> ALL SECURE FOUNDATION SERVED
PESCHEL OPERATIONS OPERATIONS,
ACTIVE DUTY IN VETERANS.
NOT ONLY THE WARRIOR, BUT THE
ENTIRE FAMILY IN HEALING FROM
THAT WE'RE TRAUMA.
THAT CAN BEAT MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS.
EVERY INDIVIDUAL IS DIFFERENT
FOR THE HEALING IS VERY
DIFFERENT.
WE LOOK AT IT THAT WAY IS AN
INDIVIDUAL INJURY AND SOMETHING
THAT ABSOLUTELY CAN BE HEALED
FROM.
>> TOM, ARE YOU INVOLVED IN
WORKING WITH THE INDIVIDUALS IN
THE FAMILIES?
R8 BOTH OF YOU INVOLVED IN THIS?
DO YOU HAVE VOLUNTEERS?
WHO AS PART OF THE TEAM THAT
MAKES THIS WORK FOR THE PEOPLE
COMING TO YOU FOR HELP.
>> WE CONSIDER OURSELVES THE
LIGHTHOUSE, WE SHARE OUR STORY,
WE SHARE, THE FEELINGS I'VE GON
THROUGH TO LET EVERYBODY ELSE
KNOW IT'S NOT AS SCARY AS IT
LOOKS AND THEN WE PASS THINGS
ALONG AND SHARE IT.
WE HAVE COACHES THAT ARE
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS THEY DO
THE HEALING AND THE HELP WORK
VERY.
>> ALL THROUGH THIS CONVERSATIO
WE HAVE HAD ON THE SCREEN